let R be the function given by R theta
is equal to three theta sine theta for
theta is between zero and two pi
including zero and 2pi the graph of R in
polar coordinates consists of two loops
as shown in the figure above so let's
think about why it has two loops so as
our theta when theta is zero R is zero
and then as R theta increases we start
tracing out this first loop all the way
until when theta is equal to pi so we've
traced out this first loop from theta is
equal to 0 2 theta is equal to PI and
then the second loop has a larger R so
these are larger R's this is when we're
going from PI to 2 pi and you might say
well why doesn't it show up down here
well between sine of PI and sine of 2 pi
this part right over here is going to be
negative so it flips it over the arm to
this side and the magnitude of the R is
larger and larger because of this 3
theta and so when we go from PI to 2 pi
we trace out the larger circle fair
enough
that seems pretty straightforward point
P is on the graph of R right over there
and the y-axis find the rate of change
of the x coordinate with respect to
theta at the point P all right so let's
think about this a little bit they don't
give us X as a function of theta we have
to figure out that from what they've
given us so just as a bit of a polar
coordinates refresher if this is our
theta right over there this is our R and
that would be a point on our curve for
this theta now how do you convert that
to X and Y's well you can construct a
little bit of a right triangle right
over here and we know from our basic
trigonometry that the length of this
base right over here this is going to be
the hypotenuse let me just write that
that's that's going to be our x
coordinate our x coordinate right over
here is going to be equal to our
hypotenuse which is R times the cosine
of theta if we wanted the y coordinate
as a function of R and theta
it'd be Y is equal to R sine of theta
but they don't want us to worry about Y
here just the x coordinate
so we know this but we want it purely in
terms of theta so how do we get there
well what we can do is take this
expression for our R itself as a
function of theta and replace it right
over there and so what we can do is we
can write well X of theta is going to be
equal to R which itself is three theta
sine of theta times cosine of theta
times cosine of theta and now we want to
find the rate of change of the x
coordinate with respect to theta at a
point so let's just find the derivative
of X with respect to theta so X prime of
theta is equal to well I have the
product of three expressions over here I
have this first expression three theta
then I have sine theta and then I have
cosine theta so we can apply the product
rule to find the derivative if you're
using the product rule with the
expression of three things
you essentially just follow the same
pattern when you're taking the product
of two things the first term is going to
be the derivative of the first of the
expressions three times the other two
expressions so we're going to have three
times sine of theta cosine of theta plus
the second term is going to be the
derivative of the middle term times the
other two expressions so we're gonna
have three theta and then derivative of
sine theta is cosine theta times another
cosine theta you're gonna have cosine
squared of theta or cosine of theta
squared just like that and then you're
going to have the derivative of the last
term is going to be the derivative of
cosine theta times these other two
expressions well the derivative of
cosine theta is negative sine theta so
if you multiply negative sine theta
times three theta sine theta you're
going to have negative three theta sine
squared theta and so we want to evaluate
this at point P so what is theta at
point B well point P does happen on our
first pass around and so at Point P
theta is
to data right over here is equal to PI
over 2 so PI over 2 so what we really
just need to find is well what is X
prime of PI over 2 well that is going to
be equal to 3 times sine of PI over 2
which is 1 times cosine of PI over 2
which is 0 so this whole thing is 0 plus
3 times pi over 2 is this 3 PI over 2
times cosine squared of PI over 2 or
cosine of PI over 2 squared well that's
just 0 so so far we everything is 0
minus 3 times pi over 2 3 PI over 2
times sine of PI over 2 squared
well what's sine of PI over 2 well
that's 1 you square it you still get 1
so all of this simplified to negative 3
PI over 2 now it's always good to get a
reality check does this make sense that
the rate of change of X with respect to
theta is negative 3 PI over 2 well think
about what's happening as theta
increases a little bit X is definitely
going to decrease so it makes sense that
we have a negative out here so right
over here rate of change of X with
respect to theta negative 3 PI over 2 is
theta increases our X for sure is
decreasing so at least it does make
intuitive sense